you're required to show emotion and and
you cried during a scene I'm Barry and I
was thinking you know that that takes
real training to be able to do that is
that something that you knew you could
do
no no I'm bad at that we have other I've
worked with other actors Sara Goldberg
is on the show she's phenomenal and she
can just you know cry and do some
amazing thing and then reset and find
little amazing intricacies within the
performance while she's doing that I'm
like it's like blowing up a bridge it
was like get three cameras on it you got
one shot at this I've cried I cry once
every year I got a lot of repressed
emotion no it's like yeah I mean I just
I can't do it the way that some of these
other people do so it is like a thing
where i'm like alright here we go here
we go we're ready and then we'll shoot
it and then i remember he did a scene
last year and i cry on stage and Alec
Berg was like wow that's great he was
directing because I was great so I need
to come in for coverage I'm like that's
it dude no that's it I can't do that
again